[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 10 mai l'enquêté
sur le meurtre du policier éric masson
conférence de presse tout à l'heure du
procureur les deux principaux suspects
déjà condamné plusieurs fois fui et en
espagne les syndicats de police sont
reçus en ce moment même à matignon ils
attendent des réponses fortes après
l'assassinât de deux des leurs en moins
de quinze jours l'armée israélienne
annonce avoir commencé a mené une série
de frappes contre des positions du hamas
dans la bande de gaza un commandant du
hamas auraient été tués des tensions qui
ne retombe pas jérusalem est un énorme
feu est signalé dans l'enceinte de
l'esplanade des mosquées le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu s'est réuni
aujourd'hui en urgence sans parvenir à
une déclaration commune les talibans
imité par le gouvernement afghan annonce
un cessez le feu de trois jours pour
l'aïd la fête musulmane qui marque cette
semaine la fin du ramadan au moins 11
personnes montent encore péri ce lundi
dans l'explosion d'une bombe au passage
d'un bus quelques heures avant cette
annonce
[Musique]
l' enquête sur le meurtre du policier
éric masson trente six ans qui a été
battu mercredi dernier en plein centre
ville d'avignon alors qu'il intervenait
un point de trafic de deal le procureur
de la république d'avignon philippe
guémas a tenu une conférence de presse
tout à l'heure les précisions de katia
technique selon le procureur d'avignon
les enquêteurs de la pj ont permis
d'identifier l'auteur potentiel des
coups de feu sur le policier éric masson
et son complice
les deux hommes souhaitent aient quitté
avignon pour se réfugier en espagne ils
ont été arrêtés par la brigade de
recherche et d'intervention à 22h30
dimanche au péage de remoulins à 20 km
d'avignon
il était conduit par un troisième homme
un quinquagénaire la soeur du tireur
présumé a elle aussi était interpellé
portant à quatre le nombre de gardes à
vue en cours
les hommes arrêtés ont 19 et 20 ans ils
ont déjà été condamné plusieurs fois
pour violences et infraction à la
législation sur les stupéfiants
l'avocat du principal suspect louis
alors le maire a déclaré que son client
contesté les faits qui lui étaient
reprochés et qu'il n'avait rien à voir
dans cette affaire
les arrestations ont été rendues
possibles grâce au travail de 80
enquêteurs travaillant à temps plein sur
la sphère la cliente du dealer a elle
aussi été interrogée elle a décrit un
contrôle policier souriant éric masson
plaisantant même sur la drogue qu'elle
avait acheté les deux jeunes hommes se
sont alors approchés et l'un d'eux a
fait feu je vous propose d'écouter le
procureur d'avignon
en toute hypothèse c'est quatre mesures
de gardes à vue se déroule sous le
contrôle des juges d'instruction et
c'est à eux et eux seuls qui
appartiendra d'apprécier s'il existe ou
non des indices graves et concordants
permettant de leur imputer les faits qui
leur sont reprochés
et si la réponse était positive leur
notifier une mise en examen
à 19h45 ce soir jean castex a réuni les
syndicats de policiers 10 millions
d'euros vont être accordées pour
renforcer la sécurité des commissariats
de police et généralise
et les caméras piétons cet été cette
entrevue se produit dans un contexte
d'épuisement des forces de l'ordre et de
chaos
les policiers demandent bien sûr une
réponse pénale bien plus lourde pour les
récidivistes et les délinquants qui
s'attaquent aux forces de l'ordre
et on vient de l'apprendre à bordeaux
une femme en état de démence a été tué
ce lundi à son domicile de pessac par un
policier qui a répliqué après qu'elle a
baissé au couteau un de ses collègues on
évoque un tir de riposte en état de
légitime défense selon une de ces
sources policières
tristesse et moi colère les syndicats de
police qui sont donc actuellement reçue
par jean castex attendent dégage du
premier ministre ils ont d'ailleurs
suspendu leur participation au bourreau
de la sécurité beaucoup d'entre eux
estiment ne pas être assez protégé c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir sur
le thème de la sécurité emmanuel macron
en at il fait assez
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
rocco contento secrétaire départemental
d'unité sgp police fo paris qui est en
direct avec nous par téléphone avec un
petit souci technique malheureusement ne
peut pas vous à voir de visu rocco
contento merci à vous d'être malgré tout
en direct
jean-michel miss député la république en
marge de la deuxième circonscription de
la loire bonsoir jean michel miss merci
d'être avec nous deux policiers tués en
l'espace de quinze jours et cet incident
ce soir à bordeaux dont on ne connaît
pas encore bien bien les circonstances 1
il s'agirait d'une femme en état de
démence qui a finalement été tué après
avoir agressé un policier reco contento
c'est clairement un point de non-retour
qu'on a franchi ces derniers jours pour
vous oui complètement on a franchi à
prendre de retour surtout parce que
notre collègue éric masson a été
délibérément tué lors d'une intervention
de police somme toute relativement banal
la veille à 25 ans ce qu'il fait les
policiers étaient les braqueurs de
banque qui étaient des personnes en
cavale qui avait 30 ans de de prison sur
la tête et là on constate que la police
ne fait plus peur est pire que ça c'est
une autorité de ce pays
on attend en pleine crise de l'autorité
de l'état qui est encore plus flagrante
depuis plusieurs années donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut absolument au delà des
actes des déclarations d'intention qui
est fait du président des médecins
gouvernement il faut vraiment agir par
des actes forts des actes forts
jean-michel miss vous êtes d'accord vous
comprenez sets et qu'arnaud absolu de la
police et que cette fois ci on ne va
certainement pas se contenter d'effets
d'annoncé il faut une des changements en
profondeur
oui je non seulement je comprends mais
je partage ce qui vient d'être dit je
crois que voyons bien aujourd'hui que
nous assistons à une montée de violence
par rapport aux forces de l'ordre et
s'est régulièrement par rapport aux
policiers qu'il était attaqué et
assassiné avec une acheter son nom
notamment
je pensais avec me semble mais cette
séquence n'est pas épargné
à côté d'eux n'est pas seulement le fait
de quelques années passées on a eu
évidemment stéphanie montferrer à
rambouillet mai mais si on remonte
simplement à 2016 avec le l'assassinât
de jean baptiste savin et de jessica
schreder aubergenville nous voyons
aujourd'hui effectivement uniforme
l'autorité que représente mes policiers
ou les gendarmes ne font plus peur pour
un chaton d'individus qui n'hésitent pas
à passer à l'acte et de manière non
seulement violente mais qui n'hésitent
pas à assassiner sans états d'âme des
hommes et des femmes qui sont au service
de notre protection rocco contento je
vais vous faire écouter avant de vous
faire réagir ce qu'en pense julien bayou
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts qui revient sur le manque
d'effectifs ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il y ait un manque de policiers c'est
la droite qui s'érige en donneuse de
leçons sur la sécurité qui les a retirés
avec la doctrine du non remplacement
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux voilà on a
perdu 15 ans aujourd'hui en 2021 vous
avez moins de policiers nationaux et de
gendarmes qu en 2007 alors que la
population augmente et emmanuel macron
est en retard puisqu'il s'en est rendu
compte que très récemment jean-michel
mise toujours ce manque d'effectifs les
parties se renvoient la responsabilité à
chaque fois la clé elle est là notamment
je pense que ce n'est pas la seule
réponse l'autorité de la police est la
priorité
on peut bien mettre autant de policiers
pour rue si elle s'attendait individus
n'ont plus peur et non plus le respect
de l'uniforme je crois que ça n'y
changerait rien quant à monsieur bayou
je suis quand même assez choqué pour pas
dire profondément choqué de ces propos
venant d'un individu de personnes qui
ont passé leur temps pendant un an à
compter c'est l'autorité de la police à
toutes les manifestations prenant fait
et cause pour ceux qui les attaquent
je pense que la décence voudrait
qu'aujourd'hui ils prennent un temps de
recueillement et ne tiennent pas de tels
propos je crois que ce n'est pas la
seule raison
effectivement le la baisse d'effectif on
peut se passer la balle les uns les
autres
mais cela ne
répondre à pas et je ne crois pas que ce
soit la demande de nos concitoyens nos
concitoyens jeunes que l'autorité de la
police et de la gendarmerie et notamment
des forces de sécurité mais pas
seulement
d'une manière générale tout ce qu'il
représente une autorité en france tout
ce qui peut représenter finalement
l'état d'une manière ou d'une autre
soient protégés ils soient accompagnés
de manière beaucoup plus forte également
on l'a vu avec samuel pâtit également un
individu seul face à des personnes
totalement contraire aux principes de la
république
il faut que cela cesse il ce n'est pas
des discours qui vont changer cela mais
bien effectivement une nouvelle est un
nouvel état d'esprit qui permettra à ces
individus de voir qu'aujourd'hui nous ne
souhaitons pas leur laisser la rue et
leur laisser le champ libre
jean-michel mise justement à ce débat de
fond il surgit de plus en plus avec ce
thème récurrent de la sécurité qui
devient éminemment politique un vin de
trois semaines après la publication
d'une tribune controversé signé par les
militaires à la retraite s'insurgeant
contre le délitement de la france va
l'heure actuelle on publie aujourd'hui
nouvelle pour la survie de notre pays en
distille écrit de cette fois-ci par des
militaires d'actifs sous couvert
d'anonymat et qui a déjà recueilli plus
de 160 mille signataires regardez une
nouvelle tribune de militaires publié
dimanche sur le site de l'hebdomadaire
valeurs actuelles appellent le président
de la république les ministres les
parlementaires et officiers généraux à
prendre leurs responsabilités pour
éviter à la france une guerre civile qui
couve nourrie par la violence et le
communautarisme
les auteurs sont tenus de garder
l'anonymat
hommes et femmes militaires en activité
de toutes les armées de tous les grades
de toutes les sensibilités
si nous ne pouvons pas réglementairement
nous exprimer à visage découvert il nous
est tout aussi impossible de nous taire
d'après le texte
une partie d'entre eux a servi à
l'étranger en zone de guerre afghanistan
mali centre afrique ou ailleurs certains
riant laisser des camarades ils ont
offert leur peau pour détruire l'islam
isme auquel vous fait des concessions
sur notre sol
la plupart ont pris part explique-t-il à
l'opération sentinelle lancée à la suite
des attentats de janvier 2015
nous y avons vu de nos yeux les
banlieues abandonnées les accommodements
avec la délinquance nous avons subi les
tentatives d'instrumentalisation de
plusieurs communautés religieuses pour
qui la france ne signifie rien rien
qu'un objet de sarcasmes de mépris voire
de haine ce lundi l'état major des
armées a tenu à se démarquer de ces
propos rappellent ferme sera fait par le
commandement sur le respect du devoir de
réserve les armées sont apolitiques et
d'une fidélité absolue au président élu
la tribune des jeunes militaires fait
suite à une première publiée par le même
site le 21 avril et dans laquelle des
généraux à la retraite au grade et
autres militaires entendaient dénoncer
le délitement de la france recontacté
quelle est la réaction du policier que
vous êtes vous voyez là une forme de
soutien
finalement pour votre profession et
surtout la tâche qui vous incombent et
qui vous encombre et si les choses
devaient parfois tourner mal comme
semble penser ces militaires où vous
trouvez vous la démarche inquiétante
dont je trouve pas les marges du tout
inquiétante mais c'est vraiment
révélateur marielle balej dans d'autres
pays pour que une tribune deux tribunes
de militaires à la retraite aussi
d'activ puisse tirer le signal d'alarmé
sur les problématiques importantes
notamment de sécurité qui sont là dans
ce pays je crois que c'est inédit mois
de mémoire je n'ai pas vu ça depuis très
très longtemps
on partage aussi ce qui est dit et je
voudrais ajouter un mot par rapport aux
sujets d'avancé que vous savez vous
pouvez mettre 3000 5000 effectifs de
plus ce sont les terrains ce qui est
important c'est le signal que j'ai
décidé qu'on donne pas bon et ça la
réponse pénale la réponse pénale qui
doit être immédiate lorsque des
personnes agressent des forces de
sécurité intérieure c'est ça le plus
important
alors je vous propose de parler
justement avant de parler de la forme de
cette tribune propose d'écouter un
gérald darmanin ce sujet il s'agit de
gens anonymes
c'est ça le courage d'être anonyme
quelle drôle de société courage aux que
celle qui donne la parole à des anonymes
on se croirait sur les réseaux sociaux
donc je n'ai pas lu la tribune des
militaires et je crois savoir parce que
j'ai beaucoup de militaires dans ma
famille tout quand on est militaire
on ne fait pas ce genre de choses en
cachette à la petite semaine
votre réaction jean michel lahmi et miss
les militaires sortent de la foule
écoutez je pense que les manière
générale on ne règle pas ce type de
problème
dans des propos anonymes porté sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense que les réseaux
sociaux sont justement l'une des causes
des difficultés pour d'autres
aujourd'hui parce que le pseudonymat qui
est donné un certain nombre d'individus
crée de la confusion et craie pour des
ailes pour les pour nos concitoyens qui
parfois surtout en des endroits
l'impression que effectivement
s'attendre de deux questions qui se
posent nous et trouveront des réponses
mais je crois que les réseaux sociaux ne
doivent pas être le lieu du débat public
ce sont des lieux de l'information des
lieux des changes mais je pense que dans
une démocratie la démocratie se vit à
visage découvert
je pense que les militaires qui
souhaitent obtenir des propos il y en a
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de militaires de
deux qualités qui sont retraite qui
peuvent s'exprimer
tu peux mettre porte parole de leurs
camarades je pense qu'il ya des moyens
je pense plus utile plus efficace de de
contribuer au débat public qu'à travers
des tribunes à l'uni jean-michel miss sk
pas une possibilité aussi de se poser la
question à l'envers peut-être que cette
démarche est choquant peut-être qu'elle
est inquiétante mais comme le disait
rocco contento il ya quelques instants
elle révèle aussi un malaise et
peut-être voilà les voies qui ne sont
pas suffisamment entendue dans ce pays
peut-être faut-il les entendre oui je
parle essentiellement de la fin je pense
que la forme n'est pas bonne cela ne
veut pas dire que ce qui est dit dans
cette tribune ou d'une manière plus
générale nous sommes en contact les élus
de la république et dont je fais partie
ne sont pas sourds les aveux
il nous entendons ce qui nous est dit
parfois de manière confidentielle
je crois que ce débat devrait
effectivement avoir lieu il n'est pas
sain dans une démocratie ont codé que
des serviteurs de la france soit
considère qu'il ne puisse pas s'exprimer
autrement qu'à travers des tribunes
anonymes donc je pense qu'il faut ouvrir
le débat revoir dialogue permettre
justement parce que cette expression
puisse se faire de manière plus
transparente et plus normal qu'elles
puissent nourrir un débat en société et
je pense que le modèle que nous
souhaitons tous ce modèle de du creuset
républicain ce modèle qui fait la
démocratie ne soit pas suppléer dans
l'esprit de certains par une addition de
communauté l'addition de communautés ne
doit pas faire la france ce qui fait la
france c'est justement l'intégration
dans la république et je pense que ce
débat là est tout à fait légitime
et en ce sens là j'entends un certain de
mon propos qui sont portées que ce soit
par des militaires ou par par la société
civile d'une manière beaucoup plus large
les militaires ne ne sont pas différents
se sont sur des sons avec des civils
bouffer des militaires
rocco contento cette tribune la deuxième
pour vous à l'ailé le reflet d'une
faillite des gouvernements du
gouvernement actuel mais d autres
gouvernements
qui ont précédé celui ci le problème
c'est qu'on savait c'est que on a eu de
mépris de l'autorité de l'autorité de
l'état et qui malheureusement à ganvié
notre pays était atteint son paroxysme
alors concernant tous ces militaires
vous savez ces courageuses qui font
parce que je vous rappelle que des
militaires que soient les gendarmes ont
coulé personnel de l'armée ont un devoir
de réserve absolu n'ont pas de
représentants du personnel et il risque
d une révocation le cas d'échec
s'exprime non pour qu'il ne fasse je
pense que vraiment il y a comme je vous
le dis à un malaise après bon sur la
forme on peut en discuter mais sur le
fond de ce qui est dit nous les
policiers nous validons parce que il est
vrai que ont malheureusement en
témoignent les des milliers de blessés
que nous avons chaque année
je vous rappelle qu'en 15 ans des
policiers de lévis dans ce comté
policiers ont doublé et les premières
victimes des attaques contre les
personnes qu'elles sont nous les forces
de l'ordre donc comme je vous le dis il
faut réagir le président lui même dans
son discours je les écoutais hier jeudi
pectoraux et m il a parlé de la réponse
pénale qui n'était pas au rendez vous
donc là dessus c'est un signal qu'il a
donnée maintenant il faut faire en sorte
que les réponses pénales soit faite que
par rapport aux agressions de policiers
des peines minimales je parle pas de
tels plans chez attention des peines
minimales en dessous desquels on ne
pourra pas aller parce que si on donne
pas à ces signaux ces bons signaux eh
bien ça va donner une appli dit et aux
délinquants qui vont continuer à
commettre leur délit en toute impunité
moi je rappelle que j'ai des collègues
qui ont été agressés par des délinquants
et dont ces délinquants n'ont écopé que
d'un rappel à la loi imaginé ce très
mauvais signal qu'on donne ça va les
confronter à continuer avec l'essai des
policiers jean-michel nice le mot de la
fin pour vous clairement votre majorité
aujourd'hui à une responsabilité plus
importante que jamais bien évidemment
puisque nous sommes ce que vous voudrez
peut-être responsabilités donc il nous
appartient d'apporter des réponses ou à
la fois effectivement aux policiers aux
gendarmes et à tous les détenteurs de
l'autorité qui sont victimes
d'agressions
on va voir malheureusement d'assassinât
dans les assises ont leurs fonctions
mais également nos concitoyens qui
évidemment attendre de de l'état une
réponse ferme qui permettent de garantir
la sécurité des biens et des personnes
c'est quand ma première vocation de
l'état dans un pays la première des
libertés c'est d'assurer la sécurité des
biens et des personnes
les choix que ça doit être une priorité
on va faire avec les lois sur la
sécurité globale qui met en place
justement un continuum de sécurité et je
pense que une partie du problème et je
crois que ça a été évoqué nous en avons
conscience puisqu'une loi sur sur
justement là la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire bas arrivent à
l'assemblée nationale et il faut que ça
continue on dut sécurité passe par une
réponse pénale adaptée
cette réponse pénale doit être immédiat
et proportionnée aux faits je crois que
ce que nous nos concitoyens n'accepte
pas c'est de voir des individus comme
est défait délinquance qu'il soit petit
ou plus important est finalement rentrer
chez eux en art aux autorités
judiciaires d'autorité delà de la police
est finalement l'autorité de l'état
je crois que cela il faut y mettre un
terme donc le premier ministre vous nous
avez rappelé reçoit en ce moment même
les représentants des forces de police à
l'hôtel matignon le président république
je pense s'exprimera dans sur ces
questions là également
et puis bien évidemment de toute manière
nous savons l'année qui est devant nous
est une allée en jeu politique très fort
nous savons que la sécurité prendra une
place important mais je crois que cela
est normal parce que ça correspond à une
attente profonde de nos concitoyens
merci en tout cas à tous les deux cocon
tantôt jean-michel mise d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france la sécurité
la survie de notre pays comme cette
deuxième tribune militaire le dirait
qu'on
viens de voir a suscité beaucoup de
réactions politiques il divise la classe
politique pour en parler nous sommes
avec alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito on est bon soir alexis poulain
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on l'a vu donc une nouvelle
tribune de militaires appellent à à
l'insurrection pour vous ou sursaut
salutaire alors je crois pas que cette
tribune appel à l'insurrection
clairement elle dit une chose c'est que
le pays n'est plus gouverné ou que
quelque chose ne va plus en france c'est
un appel à l'aide
une alerte clairement posée par des
militaires pour qui j'ai énormément de
respect qui sont sur les théâtres
d'opérations qui sont là pour défendre
les populations est le pays qui savent
de quoi ils parlent
tout comme les policiers qui eux aussi
sont en train de parler au premier
ministre ce soir et qui n'en peuvent
plus finalement d'un laisser-aller
puisque c'est un peu ça qui est
critiquée de ce quinquennat et des
quinquennat précédent de dire vous
connaissez les problèmes vous les
politiques et vous n'avez rien fait
aujourd'hui si vous ne faites rien alors
oui peut-être que nous allons entrer
dans un moment insurrectionnel dangereux
où certains parlent même de guerre
civile je crois qu'il faut pas il faut
redescendre d'un cran
il faut pas s'enflammer derrière on
parle bien sûr de signature anonyme
puisque le devoir de réserve de l'armée
est essentielle si on parle de guerre
civile c'est qu'on veut aussi peut-être
la guerre civile et c'est là où c'est
dangereux je crois qu'il ya une analyse
juste qui est le laisser-faire le
laisser aller après la réponse qui
serait celle de dire qu'il faut utiliser
les armes qu'il faut utiliser la
violence qu'il faut aller plus loin dans
cette réponse là n'est pas forcément la
bonne
mais le problème il est sur la table
aujourd'hui c'est que fait emmanuel
macron que fait son gouvernement pour
répondre à ses inquiétudes pour protéger
les populations françaises pour protéger
les policiers dans l'exercice de leur
métier
ou bien les militaires qui sont des
cibles du terrorisme islamique ça on le
sait donc je crois que c'est surtout ça
que disent ces tribunes
et puis on voit bien que comme on est
dans une année importante avant
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 et
bien elles sont utilisées et à dessein
par marine le pen notamment puisque
l'aca fait écho à des thèmes de campagne
qui lui sont chers qu elle a toujours
fait et qui a un vocabulaire aussi qui
peut être proche de celui utilisé par
les cercles 10,2 de l'extrême droite
donc voilà pourquoi cette tribune je
pense faire autant de vagues
la ministre des armées florence parly a
été obligé de se positionner par rapport
à ça en disant qu'on doit pas dire des
choses pareilles c'est saper les valeurs
de la république mais je crois qu'on
peut saper les valeurs de la république
de plein de façons différentes et il est
là toute la question c'est finalement un
débat philosophique de ce qu'est la
sécurité ce qu'est la france
et pourquoi aujourd'hui des militaires
sont contraints de sortir des tribunes
de manière anonyme
c'est du jamais vu et ça dit plus de la
feuille du politique que de la faillite
de ces militaires qui sont finalement
dans un devoir de réserve permanent et
qui là sortent de leurs gonds
alexis vous venez de le dire le thème de
la sécurité qui s'imposent de plus en
plus qui devient plus que jamais un un
enjeu politique
illustration avec les passes d'armes à
un vrai feuilleton auquel ont assisté ce
week-end entre marine le pen et eric
dupond moretti dans les hautes france
oui mais tout est là finalement on voit
bien qu eux mêmes à kron a passé son
temps à se mettre en scène dans ce
quinquennat
d'ailleurs la journée du 8 mai on le
voit se mettre en scène avec l'état
major avec un drone qui survole cette
réunion entre le président l état major
du jamais vu c'est bien sûr pour
uniquement faire des images pour
rassurer dire qu'il est le chef des
armées et donc il a choisi dans cette
mise en scène son adversaire principal
et c'est marine le pen est depuis le
début
de ce quinquennat il a tout fait pour
que en 2022 on se retrouve dans la même
situation qu'en 2017
avec ce second tour où il serait face à
marine le pen son adversaire préféré
donc il fait tout pour que ça arrive
pourquoi ils envoient monsieur dupont
moretti dans les hauts de france parce
que finalement le candidat initial de la
république met en marche ne fera aucun
score il le sait donc ils envoient un
ténor connu qui est pourtant ministre de
la justice il a autre chose à faire
uniquement pour saper les chances de
xavier bertrand de gagner largement la
région nord est pour diminuer ses
chances pour la course à la
présidentielle
donc c'est de la tactique politicienne
de bas étage dangereux puisque
finalement que fenzel macron ils misent
sur le fait que les français votent à
nouveau pour lui contre marine le pen
or les temps ont changé et beaucoup de
gens sont excédés de la politique des
valeurs acron sa base n'a pas évolué il
reste sur une base qui à peu près la
même qu'en 2017 qui s'est érodée
d'ailleurs de son côté gauche et il
essaye tant bien que mal de rattraper
sur le côté droit avec un gérald
darmanin qui en fait davantage sur la
sécurité
on voit bien qu'ils sont encore bien en
deçà de ce qui est attendu des forces de
police ou bien des populations dans les
quartiers difficiles et tout est à
l'envi avec une stratégie uniquement
d'arrivée face à marine le pen au second
tour en 2022 mais il ya un premier tour
avant le second tour
et puis il ya des idées qui sont en
train de gagner aussi celle de marine le
pen en l'occurrence qui prennent du
terrain donc ce choix de dupond moretti
c'est un choix tactique pas forcément le
plus malin mais qui en dit long sur la
tactique national de long terme d'
emmanuel macron alors justement un
dernier sondage c'est édifiant quarante
deux pour cent des français estiment que
le fn ne représente pas un danger pour
la démocratie mais ils ne sont qu'un
tiers à l'estimé capable de gouverner et
qu'un quart seulement jugé marine le pen
que marine le pen serait une bonne
président
de la république comment expliquez vous
ces chiffres par ailleurs en hausse 1
comment tout simplement parce que les
thèmes défendus par marine le pen depuis
des années sont devenus des thèmes
récurrents devenu centraux au débat
politique national que ce soit le thème
de la sécurité
le thème de l'immigration tous ces
thèmes là qu'elle a martelé année après
année que son père martelait avant elle
mais ils sont devenus au coeur de tous
les débats et puis marine le pen elle
est devenue même le centre de
l'attention de tous les politiques en
france c'est l'alpha et l'oméga de la
stratégie politique de tous les partis
que va-t-on faire face à marine le pen
il faut se positionner c'est finalement
elle qui est en train de mener la danse
d'une certaine façon en ne faisant rien
puisque les thèmes qu'elle défend des et
il ya des années sont maintenant sur le
devant de la scène
donc c'est bien ça tout le problème les
français aujourd'hui se disent eh bien
après tout peut-être qu'elle avait
raison peut-être que ces idées là
maintenant sont devenus des idées
communes ou avant vous étiez taxé de
raciste vous étiez taxe est justement
d'extrémistes c'est devenu d idée
partagée par de plus en plus de français
alors plus en plus il ya un bémol à on
parle d'un tiers d'un quart de france
est loin d'une majorité mais dans
l'isoloir il se pourrait que face au
rejet de la politique d' emmanuel macron
à ses stratégies politiciennes aussi qui
veulent affaiblir et la droite
traditionnelle et qui a siphonné
certaines voix de gauche et bien les
électeurs de droite plus classique se
tourner vers marine le pen
faute de candidats puisque aujourd'hui
on attend apparaît xavier bertrand de
savoir qui à droite sera candidat
également pour défendre les couleurs des
républicains aujourd'hui le parti n'a
pas de candidat et ne sais pas
d'ailleurs comment en désignaient il est
l'agent sans doute une partie du
problème à droite et puis marine le pen
n'a pas à faire campagne elle n'a qu'à
attendre finalement avec ses idées qui
infuse
emmanuel macron qui attend lui également
ce match retour qui pourrait cette fois
ci être tout à fait en défaveur des
monnaies le maquereau merci avec six
poulains d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous partirons à
jérusalem où les tensions ne retombe pas
au contraire
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu s'est
réuni aujourd'hui en urgence sans
parvenir à une déclaration commune
et puis direction l'afghanistan où les
talibans imité par le gouvernement
annonce un cessez le feu de trois jours
pour l'aïd
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des gandhi il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre kim est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
enfin féminicide et commis tous les deux
à trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il sous ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu réuni en
urgence aujourd'hui n'est pas parvenu à
s'entendre sur une déclaration commune
au sujet des violences à jérusalem
le texte proposé par la norvège présenté
conjointement par la tunisie et la chine
a été refusé en l'état par les états
unis
le document demande notamment israël
d'arrêter les activités de colonisation
de démolitions et des expulsions de
palestiniens selon washington je cite un
message public n'est pas opportun ce
stade la maison blanche qui a tout de
même fermement condamné les tirs de
roquettes du hamas et appelle à la des
escales à tout comme le royaume uni
de son côté paris dit craindre une
escalade de grande ampleur et appelle à
la plus grande retenue
il faut dire que sur le terrain les
tension ne retombe pas loin de là neuf
personnes ont trouvé la mort dans des
frappes sur la bande de gaza le hamas
annonce mais mort d'un de ses
commandants des salles de roquettes on
le disait en tête et sûrs et est tirée
depuis la bande de gaza alors qu'un
incendie s'est déclaré ce soir dans
l'enceinte de l'esplanade des mosquées
maxime abers des palestiniens prise au
piège devant l'esplanade des mosquées
sous les gaz lacrymogènes et les balles
en caoutchouc
situation toujours aussi explosive à
jérusalem ce lundi après un week-end de
violences
de nouveaux heurts ont éclaté dans la
ville sainte
entre policiers israéliens et fidèles
palestiniens le mur des lamentations à
lui est évacué bilan au moins 300
blessés la situation est telle que vous
la voyez ils nous empêchent d'accéder à
la mosquée il y a plus de 200 blessés à
l'intérieur il appelle à l'aide de la
mosquée on ne sait pas quoi faire
nous sommes vraiment attristés par la
situation à l'intérieur qu'est ce que
c'est que ça il y a plus de 200 blessés
à l'intérieur c'est une honte
où est la conscience
où est la conscience internationale où
est l'humanité dans le monde
est ce que la liberté existe ou non que
dieu maudisse tout ce qui nous laisse
seuls avec lena
que dieu les mots disent les nôtres au
mont du temple et aux autres lieux
inflexible le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou persiste et justifie
le recours à la force
la police israélienne et nos forces de
sécurité ce n'est pas une mission que
nous pouvons mener à bien sans entrer en
conflit de temps en temps avec ces mêmes
forces d'intolérance qui veulent nous
enlever nos droits d'abord nos droits
mais pas seulement les nôtres au mont du
temple et aux autres lieux saints nous
sommes déterminés à garantir les droits
de tous et cela nécessite de temps en
temps de se lever et de rester forts
comme le font actuellement
la police israélienne et nos forces de
sécurité nous les soutenons dans cette
juste lutte
ces choses bien sûr on été
incorrectement représentés dans les
médias mondiaux
au final la vérité prévaudra mais nous
devons persister et la dir scènes de
chaos et de représailles dans les rues
ce lundi une voiture transportant des
israéliens a été prise pour cible par
des jets de pierres après avoir perdu le
contrôle
elle a foncé sur des palestiniens
représailles aussi à gaza où des
roquettes ont été tirées en direction du
territoire israélien qui ont toutes des
manifestants du hamas se sont eux
rassemblés devant le parlement
palestinien le hamas qui a donné comme
ultimatum à israël de retirer ses
soldats de l'esplanade des mosquées
nous appelons la ligue arabe
l'organisation de la coopération
islamique et le comité de jérusalem
d'agir de toute urgence pour freiner
cette agression toutes les options sont
sur la table pour faire face à cette
agression
à l'appel de la tunisie soutien de la
cause palestinienne
un conseil de sécurité de l'onu doit se
tenir en urgence comme le hamas le
premier ministre en appelle à la
communauté internationale
ce qu'il se passe à jérusalem est un
appel au meurtre et exprime l'esprit de
criminalité de haine qui s'exprime dans
l'éducation des partis en israël
dans l'éducation scolaire et les
programmes d'enseignement
j'appelle la communauté internationale à
intervenir immédiatement pour mettre un
terme à ces violations horrible j'ai
russe et à protéger les citoyens des
territoires palestiniens surtout à
jérusalem qui subi un nettoyage ethnique
cette partie de l'asie c'est croire les
principaux lieux saints
dès aujourd'hui jerusalem redonne de
l'éclat à la cause palestinienne
loin d'apaiser les tensions
les autorités israéliennes ont entamé
les célébrations de la journée de
jérusalem
une journée qui marque la conquête de
jérusalem est par israël en 1967
cette partie de la ville où se trouvent
les principaux lieux saints des trois
religions monothéistes
pour parler de ces tensions à jérusalem
est ce nous sommes avec taoufik thani
président d'honneur de l'association
france palestine solidarité bonsoir
t'offre italie merci d'être avec nous
clairement beaucoup de tensions il y
aurait une neuf morts dont un commandant
du hamas clairement ce soir doit-on
craindre une troisième intifada que l'on
craint d'ailleurs depuis déjà plusieurs
années
neuf morts dont trois enfants en bas âge
il ya les photos qui circulent déjà sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est à dire qu' il
serait quand elles bombardent elle
bombarde sans distinction c'est une
punition collective qui touche tout le
monde et donc il ya trois enfants qui
sont qui sont morts et puis d'autres
civils au total ça fait 9
qu'est ce qu'on peut craindre une
intifada observer les ingrédients d'un
soulèvement palestinien il existe depuis
très longtemps et cette cette question
qui est question qui est centrale la
cause palestinienne n'a jamais perdu de
sa centralité elle n'a jamais trouvé
vraiment un écho auprès des décideurs du
monde entier de temps en temps il ya des
résolutions qui appelle israël à
respecter le droit international mais
knoll qui ne sont jamais appliquées et
la maintenance récemment netanyahu qui
ont difficultés électorales
il voulait créer un problème à jérusalem
pour détourner l'attention de l'opinion
publique et israéliennes palestiniennes
et internationales sur ses déboires avec
la justice donc il a allumé le feu parce
qu'il faut qu'on sache un petit peu
comment ces événements ils ont commencé
c'était au début du ramadan donc il y
avait la fermeture de la place place
devant la porte de damas aux
palestiniens qui la fréquentent souvent
tous les mois du ramadan pour eux
je discutais un petit peu entre eux
entre après la rupture du jeûne
et puis en attendant la dernière prière
de la nuit donc ça a été fermée comme ça
gratuitement ne des palestiniens et en
même temps il y avait cette
manifestation d' extrémistes israéliens
de groupes de fascistes donc d'ailleurs
aux cris de mort aux arabes
et puis des scènes de ratonnades contre
les palestiniens donc ça a commencé par
une provocation et du gouvernement et de
la police israélien et puis également
des collants qui était épaulé par par
7,7 même ce même gouvernement donc il y
avait une provocation vis-à-vis des
palestiniens
s'ajoutent à ceux ci ce qui se passe
dans le quartier de sheikh jarrah parce
que ça c'est ce qui a poussé un petit
peu les parisiens à dire basta pourquoi
nous on n'a pas le droit à une vie qu'il
est correct comme le reste de l'humanité
pourquoi des palestiniens qui habitent
dans leur résidence depuis 1948
lorsqu'ils ont été expulsés d'israël et
puis qui ont eu le droit d'avoir des
maisons avec un accord entre la jordanie
et l'onu en 1956 pourquoi maintenant il
faut qu'ils soient expulsés de chez eux
pour donner c'est leur maison à des
colons juifs qui viennent d'ailleurs
donc vous voyez il ya ces ingrédients du
soulèvement populaire il existe depuis
longtemps les palestiniens ne veulent
pas mal est fait ça ne veulent pas
exposer leur vie comme ça à des tirs de
balles réelles ou bâle ii d'ailleurs
c'est pas des balles en caoutchouc mais
des balles en europe et au caoutchouc
par ce départ en méthane ne veulent pas
exposer leur vie ils veulent de il veut
la voir
avoir une vie normale mais ils sont
poussés justement un assaut à se prendre
en charge à se soulever contre cette
agression extrême aujourd'hui tu en fis
thani clairement la communauté
internationale exprime son inquiétude
notamment la france ce soir mais les
états unis ont une voix un peu
dissonante
il condamne les tirs de roquettes en
cette fois-ci palestiniens contre l'état
hébreu
ça veut dire quoi qu'en gros il n'y a
pas vraiment de rupture avec joe biden
il est tout à fait sur la même ligne que
donald trump a sur cette question
israélo palestinienne et arrière petit
fils différence parce que deux au
conseil de sécurité etats unis
aujourd'hui ils ont dit une déclaration
publique n'est pas un et part importante
en ce moment donc il ya peut-être un
petit peu de la france aussi est là dans
le communiqué de du quai d'orsay qui a
paru aujourd'hui il est honteux
il commence d'abord par la contrainte de
tirs de roquettes
attendez les tirs de roquettes ne sait
absolument pas du tout la cause
palestinienne
mais commencer par cette condamnation
et puis en mettant sur le même pied
d'égalité les manifestants palestiniens
et puis la police qui les répriment et
puis les colons qui est qui manifestent
aux cris de mort aux arabes comme l'a
fait le communiqué du quai d'orsay
c'est honteux mais pourquoi le font-ils
tu as aussi que tannis pourquoi
parle-t-il de ses tirs de roquettes ils
estiment peut-être que ces voix là on a
du mal à savoir qui commence et c'est ça
le fond de la pensée on a du mal à
comprendre c'est pour ça que depuis tout
à l'heure j'ai dit comment ça va
commencer j'ai parlé de ce qui s'est
passé dans la place devant la porte de
damas et puis
la manifestation des colons à jérusalem
demandant de tuer les arts et vous savez
quand il ya une très forte pression
certains expliquent explosé de partout
ça c'est vraiment celle règles
élémentaires de la physique et ça
s'applique aux êtres humains donc après
il ya eu des vocables hamas mais à gaza
qui est sous blocus infernal depuis très
très longtemps donc il est possible de
maîtriser deux millions de de deux
personnes soumis à un blocus infernale
et c'est pour ça que j'ai dit tant que
la communauté internationale n'a pas
trouvé de solution à cette question
palestinienne
selon le droit international que la
légalité est anormal il va y avoir des
problèmes
or jusqu'à maintenant qu'on assiste à
une d'ailleurs la position des états
unis mais également celles de la france
ou union européenne
elles vont plutôt dans le sens de
assurer une impunité à israël ne sommes
pas dans la logique de demander des
comptes à israël israël qu'il qualifie
d' un état d'apartheid et maintenant
toutes les organisations les
co-organisateurs internationales telles
que par exemple human rights watch ou
bien des organisations qu'israélien
comme benselin et qui caractérise la
politique israélienne dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés ou bien
en israël même vis-à-vis de la lame une
eau et des palestiniens qu en étant une
politique d'apartheid l'apartheid bien
sûr toute façon il va appeler des
manifestations de protestation et de
temps en temps de la violence de ceux
qui sont sous l'occupation
par contre d'ailleurs et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment faire la différence
entre ne pas faire vraiment la symétrie
entre les deux parties les blessés quand
vous parlais tout à l'heure où dans le
reportage de 300 blessées par des 300
blessés ils sont pratiquement tous parés
signal il ya quelques blessés du côté
des forces de l'anp dgl léger les forces
plutôt de désordre et forces
israéliennes
mais ceux qui subissent la répression
sont les palestiniens les blessés sont
les falaisiens les neuf morts sur les
palestiniens
la répression s'est pas laissée
très palestiniens le blocus et contre
les palestiniens donc cette asymétrie
qui est servi par les états unis et
maintenant par la france et un certain
nombre de pays européens
elle est totalement fausse merci
beaucoup taoufik thani d'avoir été avec
mon président d'honneur de l'association
france palestine solidarité merci
d'avoir été avec nous alors qu'il ya un
véritable regard de tension à jérusalem
est où on note ce soir la mort de 9
personnes merci à vous des violences
également en irak ce week-end au cours
de manifestations après la mort d'un
militant anti gouvernementales des
assassinats politiques qui se
multiplient ces derniers jours dans le
sud du pays alors que dira qu organise
des élections en octobre prochain
quentin mauclair une nuit sous le signe
de l'embrasement l'assassinât dimanche
du célèbre militant anti
gouvernementales et à bâloise ni a
provoqué la colère dans plusieurs villes
du sud du pays
la nuit dernière ahmad hassan
journaliste de la chaîne irakienne al
fourat a été victime d'une tentative
d'assassinât
il se trouve actuellement en soins
intensifs après avoir reçu deux balles
dans la tête et une autre dans l'épaule
dans les rues la tension monte alors que
la colère s'intensifie en réaction à ces
assassinats politiques
plusieurs feux ont été déclenchés ces
deux dernières nuits à karbala
la police assure que la situation est
sous contrôle la situation sécuritaire
dans le gouvernorat de kerbala et bonne
grâce à dieu je suis ici maintenant
devant le consulat iranien avec le
commandant des opérations avec la
présence des régiments d'urgence et des
forces de briseurs de grève
la situation est bonne comme vous pouvez
le voir la route est ouverte et
net-citoyens se déplacent librement et
en général la situation dans le
gouvernement
à de karbala est bonne si dieu le veut
si la police se veut rassurante
ce n'est pas le cas des manifestants ces
derniers demandent des comptes et accuse
de la police et le gouverneur de la
ville d'être derrière l'assassinât du
militant et à bâloise ne nous demandons
au chef de la police de révéler
l'identité des assassins de l'activiste
et abel ouazzani qui a manifesté de 2015
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour le droit du
peuple irakien pourquoi at il été tué
pendant le mois de ramadan nous tenons
pour responsables gouverneur de kerbala
le chef de la police et le commandant
des opérations et s'ils ne veulent pas
assumer cette responsabilité ils doivent
révéler qui est le tueur
sinon ce sont eux qui sont responsables
de l'assassinât et abalo hasseni
dénonçait depuis plusieurs années les
groupes armés ainsi que le contrôle de
l'iran sur la ville chiite de kerbala
la mort du militant à laquelle s'ajoute
la tentative d'assassinât d'ahmed hassan
interviennent alors que des élections
législatives anticipées doivent avoir
lieu en octobre
un scrutin qui avait été promis au
peuple à la suite d'un mouvement de
contestation en octobre 2019 ce
mouvement appelé révolution d'octobre
avait été durement réprimées causant la
mort de près de 600 manifestants irakien
en afghanistan les taliban imité par le
gouvernement afghan annonce un cessez le
feu de trois jours pour l'aïd la fête
musulmane qui marque cette semaine la
fin du ramadan washington salue le
cessez le feu mais appelle à son
extension ces derniers jours de nouveaux
attentats ont été perpétrés dont l'un ce
week-end devant une école à kaboul qui a
fait au moins 50 morts l'onu tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
nicolas petit
des familles réunies dans la prière sous
un soleil de plomb
ces afghans enterrent leurs proches tués
quelques heures plus tôt dans
l'explosion de trois bombes qui ont fait
au moins 50 morts et plus d'une centaine
de blessés soit l'attentât le plus
meurtrier depuis un an des actes
fermement condamnées par l'onu le
secrétaire général condamne fermement
l'horrible attentat perpétré près d'une
école à kaboul en afghanistan
les responsables de ce crime odieux
peuvent être tenus pour responsables
le secrétaire général souligne qu'il est
urgent de mettre fin à la violence en
afghanistan est de parvenir à un
règlement pacifique du conflit
la journée de deuil national ce mardi ne
saurait masquer la menace grandissante
qui pèsent sur l'afghanistan
ce lundi une nouvelle explosion a causé
la mort de 11 personnes dans la province
de zaboul au sud du pays confirmant s'il
en est la recrudescence des violences
des dernières semaines un regain des
tensions liées au retrait des soldats
américains présents sur place et
initialement fixée au 1er mai 2021
lors de la signature des accords de doha
par donald trump
outre les retards pris ce retrait des
troupes américaines
finalement entériné au 11 septembre
prochain par joe biden laisse craindre
aux forces alliées une reprise du
pouvoir rapide par les talibans ce lundi
les autorités allemandes ont donc fait
part de leurs intentions
le niveau de violence persiste en
afghanistan est l'un des plus grands
obstacles pour mieux garantir la
protection de notre point de vue il est
extrêmement important de continuer à
travailler un cessez le feu global et
également souligné que je crois que même
après la fin de la mission militaire
notre soutien aux forces de sécurité
afghanes se poursuivra tant pour la
police que pour les forces armées
ce trail kraft alors que les talibans
livre tous les jours des combats contre
les forces gouvernementales dans
l'arrière-pays
il démentait pourtant toute implication
dans les attentats commis à kaboul
depuis les accords de doha en février
2020 ce lundi ils ont annoncé une courte
trêve un cessez-le-feu de trois jours
pour fêter la fin du ramadan
en réponse le président afghan ashraf
ghani a ordonné à ses forces armées de
respecter le cessez le feu est invité
une nouvelle fois les insurgés à mettre
fin à la guerre et pour en parler nous
sommes avec un clown blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous pour bien qu'on
comprenne pourquoi ce regain de france
aujourd'hui en afghanistan
ben je crois qu'il faut dire d'abord que
les talibans font trois reproches aux
états unis d'une part comme vous l'avez
dit dans le sujet le non respect de la
date du 1er mai pour le retrait des
troupes américaines
c'est ce qu'avait été conclu dans
l'accord du 29 février 2020 il reproche
également la libération des prisonniers
et il reproche également la non levée
des sanctions à l'égard d'un certain
nombre de dirigeants talibans
par conséquent effectivement c'est
probablement la cause de la violence et
des attentats qui ont eu lieu ces
derniers jours
certainement pour le bus qui a explosé
hier et qui a fait 11 morts que comme on
l'a dit aussi dans votre sujet pour ce
qui est de l'attentât horrible
devant cette école de jeunes filles de
jeune fille qui habite un quartier ouest
de la capitale afghane et qui est
habitée par des hasards a qui sont de
confession musulmane si il ya eu 50
morts et l'organisation de l'attentât a
été fait pour tuer puisqu'un véhicule a
explosé
les jeunes filles qui n'ont pas été tué
sur le coup sont partis en courant et
ont été tuées par la deux la deuxième
explosion
et puis les autres par la troisième
explosion alors cela dit cet attentat
n'a pas été revendiqué par les talibans
et ont su aussi que des équipes de dèche
sont actives encore en afghanistan est
déj ce n'est pas une année pas les
talibans mais c'est une marque
internationale les talibans c'est une
marque afghane
donc il ya peut-être aussi des éléments
de compétition qui entrent en jeu et qui
alimentent cette violence il ya eu
d'autres attentats et en effet des
combats armés des postes brio aux
troupes gouvernementales des tentatives
pour prendre des capitales régionales et
cela risque de continuer alors il ya
cette trêve de trois jours à cause d'eux
à l'occasion de l'aïd el fitr et il
reste à voir à savoir si cette trêve
pourrait être prolongé et quelle sera
l'attitude des talibans pendant cette
période la suite de cette brève
alors après le retrait des derniers
soldats américains est ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à une reprise du contrôle du
pays par les talibans justement c'est
toute la question est évidemment la
nature a horreur du filet la politique
aussi bien sur les talibans veulent
participer au pouvoir
est ce qu'ils veulent la totalité du
pouvoir c'est toute la question
alors abdullah abdullah qui est le
président de la laddh dehors de
l'organisme qui organise toutes les les
conversations entre le gouvernement et
les taliban entre toutes les tendances
de l'afghanistan a fait une déclaration
assez juste je crois en disant que si
les talibans ne reviennent pas à la
table de négociation de ces négociations
inter talibane après le après la fin du
ramadan
eh bien ça voudra dire sans doute que
ils ne sont pas très intéressés par la
paix et qu'ils veulent la totalité du
pouvoir par tous les moyens
mais cela dit il ya beaucoup de
ressources à l'intérieur de ressources
politiques même à l'intérieur de
l'afghanistan y compris des assemblées
traditionnelles des chefs des chefs des
différentes tribus qui peuvent votre
sied aussi être mis à contribution
une fois les américains partis et les
américains ont annoncé non seulement
qu'ils avançaient
d'abord dans un premier temps leur
départ au 4 juillet mais les chefs
militaires ont fait savoir que tout
serait probablement terminée fin juin
parce qu'il était inutile d'exposer des
vies humaines dans les conditions
actuelles
alors évidemment ça pose de nombreux
problèmes pour les alliés les américains
le retrait américain et les européens
dans tout ça quel rôle
alors il ya d'abord les européens qu'ils
sentent allié dans la coalition et que
d'américains et les principaux qui ont
les contingents les plus importants ce
sont les britanniques ce sont les
allemands d'où la réaction du ministre
allemand que nous avons vu tout à
l'heure mais aussi les italiens et les
turcs qui ont chacun plus d'un millier
d'hommes qui sont encore présents là bas
et effectivement ils dépendent
totalement des américains pour leur
logistique y compris pour leur retrait
pour leur exfiltration et du
commandement américain pour l'exécution
de ce retrait par conséquent ils sont
tout à fait inquiets en plus
effectivement ils sont à quai pour
l'avenir de ce pays pour lequel ils ont
agi pour ce qui est de la france une
érotisation un petit peu différente
puisque le président hollande avait
décidé du retrait du contingent français
qui était monté jusqu'à pratiquement
trois mille huit cents hommes et ce
retraité totalement effectué en 2014 et
que par conséquent nous ne sommes plus
dans la même situation que les allemands
mais cela dit bien entendu il ya des
français qui sont présents sur place il
y à des coopérations également avec la
police il y a par conséquent des risques
pour des citoyens français qui
travaillent actuellement là-bas à kaboul
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales rester avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du passé ni terre avec le
début aujourd'hui de l'examen à
l'assemblée nationale du projet de loi
sur la gestion de la sortie de crise un
jalon pour sortir une bonne fois pour
toute de la crise est pire
pour olivier ferrand la france repassé
sous la barre des 5000 personnes en
réanimation une première depuis le 29
mars dernier
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan moulin
station spatiale internationale c'est
une forme de diplomatie
on a très peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui
peuvent être des outils diplomatiques
aussi aux six ans outre atlantique les
états unis semblent devenir le porte
étendard d'une idée qui n'est pourtant
pas nouvelle instaurée en impôts un
minimum mondial sur les bénéfices des
entreprises plutôt que de plaider pour
un taux d'imposition minimal mondiale il
faudrait aussi plaidé pour une fiscalité
beaucoup plus transparente niveau
mondial ont fait chabou comme je
rappelle que byron n'a pas été élu
président du monde
il est trop simpliste de penser qu'amd
augmente au taux d'imposition va faire
rentrer plus d'argent dans les caisses
c'est beaucoup plus facile de noyer le
poisson en parlant dans un beau mondial
pour faire passer
une hausse des impôts chez lui vous
aurez des augmentations d'impôts dans
tous les pays
les whatever it takes le problème c'est
qu'il ya toujours un pigeon à la fin qui
est là pour pays
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous un peu long
des pratiques professionnelles
protectrice la justice à sa part dans
cette impunité comment souhaitez vous la
faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sap est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité j'ai les jambes c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue
d'une certaine façon qui sont peut-être
les meilleurs adeptes de la
mondialisation c'est à dire que ils ont
inventé les routes de la drogue bien
avant que les entreprises ne découvrent
les bienfaits de la mondialisation on ne
visualise pas à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de se retrouver avec dans son
garage montagnes de billets de banque
comme ça il faut en faire quelque chose
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses
ça a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 10 mai début de l'examen à
l'assemblée nationale du projet de loi
sur la gestion de la sortie de crise
objectif alléger les restrictions face
au co vide
parmi les mesures proposées la mise en
place d'un pass sanitaires un jalon pour
sortir une bonne fois pour toute de la
crise épidémique pour olivier ferrand
pourtant loin de faire l'unanimité alors
pour reprendre le pass sanitaires on en
parle dans quelques instants avec nos
invités
le référendum sur le climat a voulu par
emmanuel macron élus à l'épreuve du
sénat le palais du luxembourg s'est
saisi aujourd'hui du texte visant à
inscrire l'urgence climatique dans la
constitution mais souhaiterait le
réécrire un article du journal du
dimanche hier affirmé que le référendum
était tout simplement enterrer ce que
dément le chef de l'état emmanuel macron
qui a présidé cette après midi à paris
une cérémonie pour la journée nationale
des mémoires de la traite de l'esclavagé
et de leurs abolitions
une commémoration symbolique près de
vingt ans après la loi taubira qui
reconnaît la traite et l'esclavagé comme
crime contre l'humanité
[Musique]
le projet de loi concernant la gestion
de la sortie de crise sanitaire débattu
à l'assemblée nationale objectif alléger
les restrictions faso kobe 19
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite en direct david kelly fin de
l'assemblée nationale ont soir david
première lecture donc aujourd'hui au
palais bourbon des débats tendus
notamment sur le fameux pass sanitaires
oui la deuxième séance vient à peine de
débuter un au total plus de 215
amendements ont été déposés un pour ce
projet de loi est sûre la sortie des
crises sanitaires est le vote pourrait
avoir lieu dans la nuit ou demain matin
peu de députés présents au sein de
l'hémicycle
ce texte ne signifie pas un retour à la
vie normale mais elle ne fait que
consolider les pouvoirs de l'exécutif un
selon l'opposition l'objectif pour le
gouvernement est de desserrer le corset
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire prolongé
jusqu'au 31 octobre 2021
tout en restant vigilant face au co vide
n 10 n'a finalement les députés vont
voter un pour le calendrier des
réouvertures souhaité par emmanuel
macron lors de son allocution en avril
dernier l article premier est au centre
des débats
il a une plus d'une centaine
d'amendements qui ont été déposés un
pour ce même article il concerne ce
fameux pass sanitaire je vous le disais
une mesure largement décriée par
l'opposition mais aussi par certains
députés de la majorité
initialement prévu pour voyager à
l'étranger le gouvernement entend de
faire de ce document l'un des
instruments phare du déconfinement il
pourra être stocké sur l'application
tous antico vide elle les contours de ce
pass inquiète au palais-bourbon
puisqu'il sera nécessaire pour accéder à
certains lieux publics
plusieurs députés parlent de
discrimination écouter eric coquerel
député la france insoumise on nous avait
dit au départ rien qu'aux frontières et
puis maintenant il ya un moment du
gouvernement très mal fichu tout le
monde le dit puisqu'on nous dit ça va
concerner les rassemble ont le loisir
voir parce que pourquoi ça il ya droit
et pas par exemple les rassemblements
liés au delà des questions de travail ou
des questions du culte et autres déjà
bizarre
et puis en plus de sa une société qui
commencent à contrôler et surveiller
discriminer ces citoyens de d'après
leurs états de santé présumés bah je
n'ai pas très envie de vivre dedans
donc c'est un vrai choix qui fait et
quand le gouvernement dit qu'une fois
qui va être mis en place c'est pas pour
généraliser moi je n'en crois rien du
tout je crois pas du tout que le jour où
il sera mis en place
qu'est ce que le gouvernement dira un
restaurateur par exemple qui vous dirai
ce que vous avez votre pass sanitaire si
vous voulez pas le montrer s'user mois
mais monsieur mais je ne je ne vous je
ne vous ouvre pas les portes de mon
restaurant personnes donc j'ai bien peur
qu'on mette le doigt dans un engrenage
extraordinairement dangereux pour les
libertés et qui n'a aucune preuve de
deux kits de fiabilité des produits
sanitaires et pourtant david du côté de
la majorité on estime que ce pass
sanitaire est bel et bien nécessaire
ah oui stéphanie autant de contrats
balancer un sou mais nous le ministre de
la santé était pourtant contre se passe
sanitaire mais plusieurs députés de la
majorité dont convaincu notamment la
présidente de la commission des lois
yale et brawn vivait elle souhaite
ajouter des garde-fous à ce projet de
loi pour ne pas porter atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales écouter pour moi
la bonne mesure c'est ça c'est
considérer que le pass and iter est
réservé pour les grands événements les
événements exceptionnels et que pour les
évènements qui doivent s'improviser qui
ressort vraiment de la vie quotidienne
qui doivent pouvoir être vécu comme
étant réalisée sur un coup de tête je
veux dans un restaurant je vais dans un
cinéma
je dois pouvoir le faire sans
m'organiser sans le prévoir et donc sans
pour la plupart de nos concitoyens à
aller faire un test pcr plus
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart de nos
concitoyens ne sont pas encore vaccinés
donc il faut qu'on puisse avoir
voilà toutes ces actions d'impulsion
doivent pouvoir se faire sans passé ni
terre c'est vraiment très important et
il est également très important que
les personnes privées telles que les
restaurateurs les propriétaires de
cinéma de théâtre etc
il est très important qu'ils sachent
qu'ils ne pourront pas demander à leurs
clients un passani terre ils ne pourront
pas en faire un argument commercial
il ne faut pas que ce patient sanitaire
s'insère dans la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens
des mots qui se veulent rassurants vous
l'aurez compris les députés veulent
avant tout encadré à l'utilité de ce
pass sanitaires et éviter l son usage
quotidien dans les restaurants dans les
cinémas ou dans les lieux publics afin
que se passe ne devienne pas un frein
pour les français mais selon
l'opposition c'est clairement mal parti
réponse donc ce soir ou demain matin et
on suivra ça avec vous merci david
qualif en direct de l'assemblée
nationale est le projet de sortie de
crise du gouvernement on débat à
l'assemblée donc alors doit-il
s'accompagner de ce fameux pass
sanitaire c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
et avec mon pour en débattre bruno
megaman chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bonsoir
renault mégane merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous de prendre de votre temps
précieux en ce moment à vos côtés
philippe herlin économistes et essayiste
le gouvernement qui évoque donc un
canton lui à un sésame qui nous fait
miroiter le retour à la vie normale de
manière progressive et sécuriser le
médecin le médecin que vous êtes à bruno
mega man est ce qu'il est d'accord avec
ce postulat c'est voilà le sésame
nécessaire pour le retour à une vie
normale
écoutez nous sommes tous d'accord qu'il
faut désormais sortir du confinement
cette sortie ne peut se faire que
progressivement avec une réouverture
échelonné des différentes types
d'activités est interaction sociale et
des lieux culturels
alors il faut que cette sortie bien sûr
se fasse en sécurité donc pour cela il
faut maintenir les mesures barrières le
port du masque dans les espaces clos
public mais il faut aussi garantir dans
les grands rassemblements que ceux ci ne
se transforme pas en luster géant et
donc effectivement le pass sanitaires
pour être y aider par ailleurs
évidemment l'ensemble des pays de la
planète sont imposés la nécessité d'être
vaccinés ou de produire un test pcr
garantissant que la personne qui rentre
dans le pays n'est pas porteuse du virus
ou un risque très faible de propager le
virus et donc de fait si vous souhaitez
voyager à l'étranger
vous allez devoir présenter votre
certificat de vaccination ou certificat
de pcr négatif et donc ça corrobore
l'intérêt de ce pass sanitaires à
nouveau alors avant de rentrer dans les
détails de ce pass sanitaires philippe
herlin c'est aussi beaucoup
question de survie économique en se
passe sanitaire aujourd'hui c'est une
mauvaise façon de poser le problème
le pass à lithaire c'est une c'est une
discrimination parce qu'on va établir
deux catégories de citoyens
ça ça ça rappelle ça évoque le crédit
social chinois pour distinguer les bons
citoyens qui se sont fait vacciner des
mauvais citoyens qui ne sont pas fait
vacciner
et puis il faut comprendre que derrière
le passeport sanitaires ayant fait
l'obligation de vacciner alors comme le
gouvernement ne peut pas imposer
l'obligation aux français de se vacciner
il fait impasse sanitaires alors
évidemment le passé et rc soit la
vaccination soit le test pcr mais les
gens au bout d'un moment on oran ras le
bol de faire un test à chaque fois
qu'ils vont soit dans un salon soit dans
une enceinte sportive soit au concert
est donc finalement ils feront le vaccin
pour pour être débarrassés du problème
donc il ya une obligation de vaccination
en fait derrière ça et toujours avec le
prétexte du cluster luck leicester qui
est qu'est toujours le sort de bons cela
qu'on pourrait avoir à chaque fois des
kits derek jamais parce que je rappelle
que plusieurs fait plusieurs plusieurs
est parti en bretagne ou ailleurs où
nous a dit c'est scandaleux les jeunes
se rassemblent et ça va faire un cluster
n'a jamais rien remarqué après et je
signale que dans de nombreux pays pas
aux états unis il ya plusieurs états qui
ont complètement des confiné au texas il
ya déjà des enceintes sportives des
matchs de baseball avec des milliers de
personnes sans masque et sans espace
seniors 100 sièges vides sans jauge à
50% ou on ne note aucun retour du nombre
de cas donc cette histoire de clusters
cesser ça ne tient pas la route
c'est une façon d'obliger les français à
se vacciner
moi je dis que la machination ça ne
correspond pas du tout à ce qu'il faut
faire parce qu'on n'est pas en phase une
maladie qu un taux de létalité ou de
mortalité dans tess anglais en face de
la peste bubonique on en face d'une
maladie je rappelle un chiffre très
simple de santé publique france
si on prend les moins de 65 ans sans
comorbidités ça représente 2 % des décès
seulement ça veut dire que quand pour
toute la population active étudiantes et
les jeunes en bonne santé
on a on est quasiment aucune chance de
dette de décéder du duc au vide donc la
vaccination dans ce cadre là n'a pas de
sens voilà simplement qu'il faut la
réserver aux gens fragiles je voyage pas
que ça m'arrange beaucoup d'avoir un
médecin pour vous contredire ou pas
votre pote de votre avis c'est pas c'est
pas le sujet mais en tout cas quittiez
les compétences nécessaires pour vous
apporter
l'argumentation en tout cas qui
s'imposent bruno mais garden qu'est ce
que vous répondez parce que c'est vrai
que ce que nous dit philippe herlin ça
correspond à voilà une partie aussi de
l'opinion qu'il faut entendre qu'est ce
que vous répondez donc alors je suis
d'accord effectivement l'un des
objectifs du passani terre c'est aussi
encourager à la vaccination
mais pourquoi parce que c'est dans
l'intérêt de la personne elle même
alors d'abord si cette personne est plus
de 50 ans et bien je suis désolée elle
court un risque de mourir ou de faire
une forme grave de covin 19
donc c'est dans son c'est un bénéfice
direct individuel maintenant si cette
personne est de moins de 50 ans en co
morbidités je suis d'accord que le
risque de décès est relativement faible
mais c'est là où la vaccination devient
un acte altruiste
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement lorsque
la personne va se thaksin et elle va
aider à réduire la circulation du virus
elle va aider à réduire le risque
d'émergence de variants résistant aux
vaccins et donc indirectement protéger
les autres ses parents c'est en tous les
cas je vous coupe parce que c'est une
question que je me pose d'ailleurs
souvent intime personnel tout simplement
quand on est vacciné est ce que ça nous
empêche d'avoir le virus je ne crois pas
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut quand même
le transmettre n'est ce pas alors non
d'abord ça empêche à presque 100 % le
risque de tomber gravement malade
ensuite ça réduit de façon très
significative le risque de faire une
forme mineure et ça réduit bien sûr le
risque de contaminer même si je suis
d'accord ça n'empêche pas le portage par
contre la charge virale est tellement
réduite
il en ce qu'il en découle immédiatement
un risque diminué de transmission du
virus
c'est grâce à la vaccination que nous
pourrons atteindre ce fameux état de
covile 0 où effectivement la vie d'avant
pourra reprendre
philippe herlin quand le docteur m'égare
ban nous dit ça on a tous envie de la
retrouver
cette cette vie d'avant est ce que
aujourd'hui on a vraiment le choix
c'est une question que je vous pose la
vie d'avant comme j'ai tout à l'heure la
vie d'avant elle revient dans plusieurs
états américains il ya plusieurs pays
les pays en afrique où on est parce qu
il n'y a pas que le vaccin qui est utile
il ya aussi des traitements comme ils
ont aussi plus reculé vers victimes qui
peuvent qui peuvent contribuer à
diminuer la charge virale c'est pas des
solutions magiques mais ça contribue à
soi à lutter pour cette maladie c'est un
élément parmi d'autres le vaccin ce qui
est un autre qui est fondamentale
notamment pour les personnes qui
acceptent qu'ils sont fragiles deux
stars étaient fortement déconseillés
voire interdite en france un d'hydroxyde
chloroquine avec les débats que l'on
sait à sur la base d'une fausse enquête
du land 7 qui a été démonté quelques
jours après mais l'interdiction n'a pas
été levé donc ça c'est tout notre
affaire on va on peut y revenir si vous
le voulez mais bon match et il est
évident il ya des ja nombreux pays qui
utilisent des traitements qui permettent
de réduire la charge virale et le et les
vaccins oraux si un intérêt tout à fait
fondamental pour les personnes qui sont
fragiles que les comorbidités parce que
ça ces personnes-là siège si elle
attrapa le une forme grave du virus
elles peuvent vraiment mourir donc ça ça
a un intérêt si elles veulent se faire
vacciner il faut qu'ils puissent le
faire tout à fait d'accord mais
présentait le vaccin comme l'unique
solution cccc démenti par les faits et
puis et puis ce qui risque d'arriver
aussi c'est que ça va être un peu comme
le vaccin comme la grippe c'est à dire
qu'il faudra le faire tous les ans il ya
déjà germaine tony hawk un peu vendu la
mèche
croyant certainement bien faire en
disant qu'il faudrait faire le vaccin
tous les ans on va comme il ya des
nouveaux variants car ils verront pas
toujours nous demander de refaire des
des vaccins tous les ans bon c'est comme
si on demandait de faire le vaccin
contre la grippe a à toute la population
pour protéger les personnes fragiles il
ya certaines années la greffe et
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de morts
lors c'est pas autant que le pot vide
mais
mais ça représente quand même des morts
un nombre de morts c'est important on va
pas obliger tous les français à se
passionner contre la grippe tous les ans
ce prétexte de diminuer le nombre de
personnes touchées par la grippe c'est
aussi aux personnes qui sont fragiles
d'être informé de pouvoir se faire
vacciner si elle le souhaite et de
prendre leurs dispositions en voilà mais
on peut pas imposer sa toute la
population donc pour le kobe c'est la
même chose bruno mega man
c'est vrai que cet argument d'ailleurs
le pdg de modern à nous un petit peu
prévenu qu on devrait vivre avec et
certainement devoir se faire vacciner
chaque année c'est vrai que ça paraît
compliqué à imposer aux français
alors pour le moment il n'est pas
question encore de ceux d'une
vaccination chaque année mais
effectivement il existe une possibilité
que cela devienne nécessaire mais
récemment laboratoire pfizer aaa a
confirmé que son vaccin actuel est
parfaitement efficace contre l'ensemble
des variantes qui circulent aujourd'hui
et donc ne recommande pas de nouvelles
injections
on pense que l'immunité vaccinale
pourrait durer deux à trois ans donc si
d'ici trois ans le virus continue à
circuler il est possible effectivement
qu'il faille seront vaccinés mais
aujourd'hui rien est acquis dans ce sens
alors par contre
j'allais dire en corriger les encourager
la vaccination des personnes plus jeunes
des personnes sans comorbidités
contribuer à réduire le risque pour les
personnes à plus haut risque de
contracter le virus parce que ça va
diminuer la circulation du virus
et ça c'est un point essentiel car plus
les virus circulent et plus les variants
résistante la vaccination apparaissent
et donc que l'ensemble des adultes en
france soient vaccinés est aussi un
garant pour permettre évidemment de deux
d'éviter les mesures de restriction le
confinement qui devrait malheureusement
être imposée si le nombre de personnes
fragiles s'infecter et en est à nouveau
en compte
les services hospitaliers il suffit que
un certain pourcentage de la population
refusent la vaccination pour que
malheureusement le les services
hospitaliers avec un nombre de lits
limitée soit saturé et qu'on file à
nouveau imposé des restrictions
enfin à ce jour il faut quand même
redire qu'il n'y a aucune preuve qu'un
certain nombre de traitements dont ils
et dont il s'est agi que ce soit
l'ivermectine l'hydroxyde chloroquine
l'azithromycine les antibiotiques
préviennent en quoi que ce soit les
formes graves ou les formes
symptomatiques voire encore mieux
la contagiosité de l'un commis 19
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant et là je
suis d'accord qu'il ne faille pas
poursuivre la recherche pour mettre au
point des médicaments efficaces pour
traiter les formes initial de la maladie
et le mot de la fin pour philippe er là
encore faut-il a manifestement que ces
médicaments et ses vaccins soit approuvé
par l'union européenne ça veut dire
qu'il y aura une inégalité entre les
différents citoyens si un russe vacciner
au spoutnik vais venir en france voilà
qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir ce qu'il va pouvoir venir en
france avec son footing mais parce qu'il
n'aura pas été approuvé par par l'europe
alors ça c'est un problème qui peut se
poser c'est le problème du voyage entre
pays
c'est clair que ça risque d'obliger à se
faire vacciner de la même façon qu'avant
même le coville quand on voulait aller
en afrique il fallait sur vacciner porte
ou en asie il fallait se faire vacciner
mais je veux dire moi je veux revenir
sur cette si ce qui me paraît comme une
discrimination j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement était un peu n'importe quel
prétexte parce que nous dès qu'il faudra
le passager terre sera obligatoire pour
les événements depuis mille personnes en
intérieur ce qui peut encore aller
limite se comprendre mais aussi en
extérieur alors qu'on sait qu'il n'ya
pas de contamination en d'extérieur donc
donc c'est un peu un prétexte je vois
qu'alain son gouvernement vient de
décider que des terrasses calero vers le
19 mai devrait être devrait avoir une
jauge de 50% ça c'est vraiment
complètement grotesque parce qu'on est à
l'extérieur il ya pas de risque de
contamination mais c'est comme s'il
fallait créer cette peur créé cette
crainte pour justifier le pass le pass
and it herbe
moi je vois plus un objectif politique
derrière lui
vaccination et de croyance que le vaccin
à lui tout seul va tout régler alors que
je dis qu'il faut envisager tout un
panel d'actions médicale
il ya des traitements à qui existe
d'autres à chercher et ce qui importe
c'est que ce soit les personnes fragiles
qu'ils soient suivis qui soit prise en
charge qui soient conscientes du
problème plutôt que de vouloir vacciner
tout le monde merci merci à tous les
deux bonhommes égard ban philippe herlin
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france est toujours sur le front du
commis de la france en train de se
sortir durablement de cette crise
sanitaire c'est ce qu'assure jean castex
au parisien ce soir les bars et
restaurants eux pourront bien ouvrir
leur terrasse au 19 mai mais avec la
moitié de leurs capacités d'accueil côté
sérum tous les plus de 50 ans peuvent se
faire vacciner dès aujourd'hui avec cinq
jours d'avancé même temps le calendrier
initial on rappelle l'ouverture de la
vaccination pour tous à partir du 12 mai
en fonction des doses disponibles au
total à ce jour plus de 17 millions de
français ont reçu une première dose et
une campagne de vaccination qui se
heurte toujours à la défiance autour de
d'astrazeneca dont l'avenir est de plus
en plus floue la commission européenne a
choisi de ne pas renouveler de
renouveler pour le moment c'est comment
d'après le mois de juin une annonce
sawyer du commissaire européen en charge
du commerce extérieur thierry breton qui
ne ferme pas la porte même si bruxelles
a dévoilé un nouveau contrat avec pfizer
bio ntech le 8 mai dernier
on regarde ce qui se passe on verra
astrazeneca est un vaccin très
intéressant il a été découvert par des
chercheurs d'oxford
il est très bon il a surtout l'intérêt
de pouvoir être utilisés dans des
conditions logistiques et de
températures plus simple et coup d'envoi
également aujourd'hui des autotests dans
les lycées si l'exécutif se veut
rassurant les proviseurs ressemble
sceptiques quant à la fiabilité de cette
opération de dépistage massif plus de
précision avec baisse chez lui devant un
lycée de boulogne billancourt en région
parisienne un défi qui s'annonce
irréalisable le ton est donné par les
chefs d'établissement à des lycées alors
que s'ouvre ce lundi la grande campagne
d'auto test auprès
lycéens le projet du gouvernement en
matière de lutte contre le coc vide
semble piétiner
avant même son lancement matériel en
nombre insuffisant manque de locaux
moyens humains trop peu nombreux et
pourtant c'est hot hot est présenté sous
forme de tests antigénique sur
prélèvement nasal était censé arriver
lundi dernier dans les lycées
problème tous les personnels n'ont pas
reçu leurs tests selon le ministère de
l'éducation nationale 60 millions
d'autos tests devraient être livrés
d'ici l'été aux établissements scolaires
les premiers entre le jeudi 6 mai et le
11 mai des annonces loin de rassurer les
principaux syndicat des chefs
d'établissement qui pointe du doigt une
mauvaise gestion de ces tests certains
même parle de gâchis en perspective au
vu du calendrier
face au manque de personnel pour faire
passer ces autos tests et les livraisons
au fil de l'eau la mise en place de ce
dépistage est impossible au lycée nous
conseillons très fortement à nos
collègues de ne prendre aucun risque
avec ces opérations on ne les réalisant
que si tout est uniquement toutes les
conditions sont remplies au regard des
préconisations sanitaires si les
livraisons d'autotest sont acheminés
trop tard dans les lycées une partie va
rester sur les bras de l'administration
car dès début juin les élèves ne seront
plus très nombreux à venir dans les
établissements livraisons retardées
autorisation des familles manquantes ou
encore mauvaise gestion du calendrier la
stratégie de dépistage du gouvernement
semble connaître un coup d'envoi raté
alors que le dispositif devrait être
élargi aux collégiens d'ici début juin
les discothèques à présent les
exploitants seront fixés le 15 juin au
plus tard sur la date de leur
réouverture et pourront bénéficier d'une
prise en charge étendue de leurs coûts
fixes
c'est ce qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui le
ministre délégué aux pme alain visé un
secteur a évidemment durement touchés
regardez ce reportage d'estelle farge et
renault parquet l'aurait signé pierre
bazaille
malgré son nom cet établissement n'aura
pas échappé aux restrictions comme les
bars et restaurants partout en france
cette boîte de nuit est totalement
fermée depuis plus de six mois six mois
de dancefloor vide et silencieux
- sans le moindre client sans la moindre
recette pour tenter de survivre
la propriétaire du privilège a dû se
reconvertir au moins temporairement
depuis deux semaines ceux qui se rendent
sur ce parking ne viennent pas se
déhancher mais acheter les produits
locaux que priscilla eu propose
désormais carottes navets tomates banane
et mandarines des fruits et légumes mais
aussi des poulets rôtis et des fromages
en lieu et place habituelle des
cocktails l'appétit gagnent ce que
l'afld est hyper le seul moyen selon
cette professionnelle d'amortir ne
serait ce qu'un peu les pertes dues à la
pandémie
c'est la seule alternative que j'ai pour
1 pour remonter la pente en entre
guillemets non bien évidemment dans on
va pas en vivre mais ça va permettre
d'apurer un peu les d'apurer un peu des
factures pour pouvoir m'en sortir j'ai
quand même du monde malgré tout bon
c'est ses limites pour pour tout régler
mais ça aide énormément
ces produits me permettent de tenir la
discothèque de boue
le comble pour priscilla c'est qu'elle
avait acquis son établissement quelques
mois seulement avant la crise du coc
vide en juin 2019 précisément des mois
de travaux plus tard après avoir investi
près de 140000 euros dont dix-huit mille
euros en matériel spécial qu'ovide le
privilège a enfin pu ouvrir ses portes
mais pas pour longtemps quinze jours
avec un jour c'est ça fait mal ça envie
de vivre
tout était aux normes on avait fait
passer la commission de sécurité
tout était bon j'avais plus qu à gémir
un mur des artistes parce que je connais
des artistes qui était prévu bien sûr
tout ce qu'on avait on a tout mis dedans
à la frustration de voir son
établissement vide s'ajoute le deuil
priscilla compter sur son mari pour
gérer l'établissement
mais ce dernier est décédé la semaine
dernière passe par une période difficile
donc mon état d'esprit mauvais deal est
simple c'est il faut qu'on rouvre
absolument sinon et on est foutu
je peux tenir encore quelques mois mais
après heureusement il y aura pas trop de
solution priscilla upa déjà prévu
d'installer une terrasse le 19 mai une
demi solutions pour tenir en ces temps
de vaches maigres
selon le syndicat national des
discothèques et lieux de loisirs
fin janvier 2021 près d'un tiers d'entre
elles avaient déjà mis la clé sous la
porte
assez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du référendum sur le
climat voulue par emmanuel macron à
l'épreuve du sénat depuis aujourd'hui il
souhaite d'ailleurs réécrire le texte le
sénat et puis nous reviendrons sur la
cérémonie pour la journée nationale des
mémoires de la traite de l'esclavagé et
de leurs abolitions président dès cet
après midi par le chef de l'état
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public et je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune c'était
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour alors je suis arrivé en
2005 pour étudier dernière fois c'était
en 2011 demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée enfin les français
ne savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la cour géoéconomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
21h30 souhaité bienvenue en direct sur
arte france si vous nous rejoignez le
sénat s'est saisi aujourd'hui de la loi
climat après son adoption en première
lecture par l'assemblée nationale
dominée par la droite la chambre
pourrait modifier en profondeur le texte
un débat qui promet d'être houleux alors
que l'exécutif et la majorité de droite
au sénat ne s'accordent pas sur les
modifications de la constitution qu un
projet de loi engendrerait en cause
notamment la question de la modification
de l'article 1 de la loi fondamentale on
écoute plusieurs sénateurs interrogé
aujourd'hui par sébastien dufour il ya
un amendement qui sera proposée qui a
été proposée par le président de la
commission des lois pour modifier donc
l'article 1 et la proposition du
gouvernement afin que les principes de
conciliation c'est à dire qu'ils sont
intégrés dans l'article 6 déjà de la
charte de l'environnement puissent être
de nouveaux effectifs et donc on a
changé clairement deux verbes qui passé
du verbe agir au verbe préservés
notamment
et tout ceci pour sécuriser
juridiquement cet article mais je pense
que de toute façon nous allons
travailler pour peu de chose puisque
vraisemblablement ce référendum n'aura
pas lieu qu'en fait bon il était destiné
à
pour le président de la république à se
redonner un petit peu de virginité si
vous voulez par rapport au manque
d'ambition de sa de 2,2 de sa loi sur la
préservation de l'environnement il sa
réponse aux 150 citoyens
le sénat va faire son travail habituel
qui tient compte l'avis du conseil
d'état
nous ne souhaitons pas que l'on puisse
importer dans le texte le virus de la
décroissance au moment où les trois
quarts des français veulent concilier le
développement économique et la
préservation de l'environnement et nous
serons très exigeant parce qu'il s'agit
de modifier la constitution
et bien alors on va on va bien voir je
trouve que c'est très bien d'inscrire
symboliquement dans l'article 1 de la
constitution la préservation de
l'environnement je suis pour
et c'est vrai que le terme garantir sur
lequel
on travaille beaucoup depuis plusieurs
semaines ça ne peut pas aller on ne peut
pas écrire garantir ce n'est pas dans la
loi sur le plan strictement juridique ce
que on pourrait comprendre un cirque de
garantir ça sous-entend une des moyens
ça sous-entend forcément une obligation
moyens qu'on ne peut pas être écrire
dans la loi de cette façon pour en
parler nous sommes avec jérôme bascher
sénateurs l air de loire dans les hauts
de france bonsoir et on va faire merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france ont bien d'entendre une de vos
collègues un sénatrice on ne peut pas
écrire le terme garantir dans la
constitution c'est ce qu'on nous dit du
côté de votre party les républicains
qu'est ce qui vous gêne temps assez
l'insécurité juridique dans lequel at
elle du t1 plongerait l'ensemble du pays
c'est important d'aider la constitution
toutes les 5 minutes et on vous met pas
de n'importe quel mot dans la
constitution
et on veut faire porter au conventionnel
de la convention pour le climat de
responsabilité jury d'eau qui est au
delà de leurs compétences et je le vis
très gentiment je suis pas spécialiste
de tout je suis pas spécialiste de droit
constitutionnel mais vous avez entendu
juste avant mon collègue c'est
chaleureux et professeur de droit
constitutionnel
professeur de voir si serré dans la vie
et qui vous a parfois expliqué que le bo
aux garanties mais pas le bon bout
donc nous avons repris ce que tous ceux
qui savent bien écrire droit le conseil
d'état la commission des lois du sénat
avait ses grands professeurs et bien
nous disent nous laissons le gros
préserver et nous faisons référence par
ailleurs à la charte de l'environnement
que jacques chirac avait fait mettre
dans la constitution et qui est
largement suffisant
c'est un
l'actuelle proposition avec garantie
c'était une erreur du gouvernement qui
veut évidemment jamais se déjuger quand
bien même fait des erreurs et je peux
vous dire une chose un petit secret
c'est que c'est un certain nombre de
conventions elle nous aujourd'hui
vous savez nous le mot garantiront
préserver ça vous est parfaitement légal
c'est vous les spécialiser les questions
du droit mais voilà ce que l'on veut et
bien nous avons traduit en termes
juridiques ce qu'il voulait ce que
maintenant alors un autre juriste quand
même assez éminent le garde des sceaux
lui même un eric dupond moretti lui il
dit
il dit assumer les avocats bon il dit
assumer devant les sénateurs l'emploi de
ce verbe garantir qui selon lui marque
la force de l'engagement du gouvernement
en faveur de l'environnement d'ailleurs
on l'a vu hier dans le journal du
dimanche
on commence à y avoir des voix à la
république en marge qui nous disent en
gros ce sont les républicains qui vont
vous faire capoter nos ambitions on
voulait faire un référendum et voilà ils
veulent réécrire toute la loi donc la
faute à vous aux républicains que leur
répondez vous alors tout d'abord je vais
vous reprendre sur un éminent juriste
qui serait le garde des sceaux c'est un
avocat pénaliste qui a l'habitude du
droit orale là il s'agit de faire la
constitution il est par habitant est
inconstitutionnelle le garde des sceaux
a souvent des formules et des et qui
font plaisir à la télévision mais là il
ne s'agit pas faire plaisir ni aux
médias ni à les jurés il s'agit d'écrire
la constitution c'est un autre métier
on voit bien qu'il ne l'a jamais je dis
bien jamais fait donc ceci étant dit
pour répondre à votre question non c'est
une erreur du président la république
qui a tout promis aux vidéos
conventionnelle sur le climat pour leur
faire croire que
c'était je vais dire une bonne idée et
leur a dit oui sans racines eux ils
n'avaient en fait rien à leur dire
ils ne savaient pas quoi leur dire pour
leur faire avaler la pilule
un premier référendum etc mais non on n
y sommes opposés au référendum qu'on
fasse un référendum sur notre test
c'est un bon test et nous y sommes
favorables
donc nous sommes favorables à un
référendum sur ce desk à partir d'un
texte bien écrit et partir de n'importe
quoi faut arrêter de me prendre de faire
la faire à la loi ce qui n'est pas fait
pour faire on écrit des choses
proprement
car il ya déjà des choses dans le bloc
de constitutionnalité saint denis
c'est à dire la chan de l'environnement
comme les comme les droits de l'homme
vous savez la déclaration des droits de
l'homme c'est comme la charte de
l'environnement c'est dans la
constitution française c'est dans le
bloc de constitutionnalité françaises
ont fait pas n'importe quoi avec les
tests ça commence à suffire
l'amateurisme
vous savez le président de la république
avait dit à un moment il ya un an un an
et demi aux députés vous pouvez fiers
d'être des amateurs
c'est un thème dommage de faire les
textes de loi et où faire la partition
comme des amateurs ne peuvent être fiers
d'eux si c'est ça qu'ils veulent
jérôme bascher donc au boulot dit tout
de même sur l'intention
vous êtes finalement assez pour c'est
vraiment qu'une question de sémantique
ou clairement vous créez vous craignez
une obligation de résultat derrière sarr
sémantique avec peut-être des
obligations qui vous déplaît
c'était pas de la saison 6 et 6 3 le
français est écrit clairement c'est
l'article de la constitution la langue
française elle français c'est pas le
charabia
c'est pas le porte-voix c'est pas le
langage parlé c'est la sécurité
juridique de la constitution et de
l'ensemble des nouveaux qui découle de
la constitution ont fait pas n'importe
quoi en réécrivant les choses comme ça
auger d'une convention pour faire
plaisir à quelques-uns non là le climat
l'environnement
tous se hisse au timbre c'est à dire
jacques chirac je rappelle je voudrais
bien qu'il était là car faire à l'époque
qui a fait m
puis à l'ump l'a fait mettre dans la
constitution la charte de
l'environnement
alors nous avons pris notre dame
peut-être qu emmanuel macron veut avoir
un succès des cimes avec un référendum
est prêt à tout mais là encore il joue
double jeu il fait semblant mais voilà
c'est tout ce qu'il fait il ne fait pas
il fait semblant de faire plaisir et en
fait il déplaît et jeffrey qu'il des
lésions de plus en plus c'est pour cela
qu'ils aiment monter l'extrême droite
ces monnaies c'est aussi pour ça qu'elle
est montré et de l'extrême gauche est
aussi montée de la colère des
écologistes
aujourd'hui clairement le bilan
justement écolo des manuels
macron vous le jure je riais comment
aucun bilan aucun bilan et musique
aucun vous avez changé de ministre à
plusieurs reprises voilà rien
strictement rien et la convention et l
j'allais dire le la sortie du chapeau et
c'est tout et le lapin tessier une
illusion comme tout ce que fait le mal
qu on est dans l'illusion et on n'est
pas dans le faire il faudrait vraiment
faire les français zones que l'on fasse
tout la planète comme pour leur sécurité
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup jérôme bascher
sénateur a l'air de loison les hauts de
france merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france emmanuel macron qui
a présidé cette après midi à paris une
cérémonie pour la journée nationale des
mémoires de la traite de l'esclavagé et
de leurs abolitions aucun politique n'a
pris la parole au cours de cette
commémoration ce sont des enfants qui
ont lu des textes en mémoire des quatre
millions de personnes ayant vécu
l'esclavagé dans les colonies françaises
jusqu'en 1848 une cérémonie symbolique
près de vingt ans après la loi taubira
qui reconnaît la traite et l'esclavagé
comme crime contre l'humanité les
explications en images le 10 mai 2011
les sénateurs adopté en deuxième lecture
et à l'unanimité le projet de loi
tendant à la reconnaissance de la traite
de l'esclavagé en tant que crime contre
l'humanité
cette loi est finalement promulguée le
21 mai 2001 mettant fin à plus de deux
ans de débats législatifs pour un projet
porté par christiane taubira alors
députée de guyane la loi taubira pour
but de mettre fin à 150 ans de silence
politique sur la traite négrière qui a
coûté la vie à plusieurs milliers de
personnes dans les colonies françaises
vingt ans après plusieurs avancées voulu
par cette loi ont eu lieu notamment sur
le sujet de la réparation politique et
mémorielles le 10 mai a été érigée comme
journée nationale de la commémoration
des mémoires de la traite négrière
de l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions
les programmes scolaires ont été
enrichies et une fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé et un mémorial
ont vu le jour à paris à pointe-à-pitre
mais un grand débat reste pour l'instant
sans réponse celui de la réparation
matérielle pourtant évoqué des
l'abolition définitive de l'esclavagé en
alors que le congrès américain a adopté
le projet de loi portant le principe
d'une compensation financière pour
réparer les méfaits de l'esclavagé aux
états unis le débat est encore au point
mort dans l'hexagone ce débat est
interminable parce que le crime en soi
est irréparable que personne ne peut
ramener les vies perdues ni remboursé
les générations de travail gratuit et
puis il y à des réparations dues parce
qu'au moment de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
on n'a pas donné à ces personnes qui
étaient encore vivantes les moyens de
vivre personne n'a de légitimité pour
esquiver le sujet de la réparation
on ne peut pas continuer à dire qu'il
n'y a pas de sujet c'est insupportable
cette dénégation emmanuel macron ne
s'est pas exprimé officiellement sur la
question préférant mettre l'accent sur
le volet mémorielle
le chef de l'état a notamment promis la
création d'un mémorial national aux
tuileries pour rendre hommage aux
victimes de l'esclavagé
ce projet qui devait voir le jour en
2021 a été retardé en raison de
dissensions sur le choix des artistes
sélectionnés et pour en parler nous
sommes avec olivier le cour grandmaison
historiens politologues bonsoir
le cour grandmaison merci d'être avec
nous une journée plus que symbolique
avec les 20 ans de la loi taubira mais
uniquement symbolique ou avec davantage
de portée selon vous à mon avis
essentiellement symbolique je constate
et christiane taubira l'a dit avant moi
d'autres également qu'elle est belle eva
conquis il ya cinq jours la prononcer un
discours important et pour rendre
hommage à napoléon et kylie a par la
suite également de participer à des
cérémonies n'a aujourd'hui on se dit
mais elle pas prononcer une parole
il est vrai que le constat la
comparaison est pour le moins singulière
je rappelle que le porte parole du
gouvernement et gabriela talent avait
dit que le président de la république et
le gouvernement vous souhaitez regarder
l'histoire en face je crains que sur ce
chapitre
emmanuel macron le soufre d'un strabisme
divergent assez orienté vers la droite
emmanuel macron qui a pourtant estimé
injustement lors de son hommage au
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon que
la décision de l'empereur de rétablir
l'esclavagé avait été une trahison de
l'esprit des lumières donc il dit c'est
tout même positionné une crise ont
assurément et pardon mais la découverte
des parts à 40
d'une part parce que contrairement à ce
que certains disent et affirme le pour
justifier cela
la critique de lestage est antérieure à
la à son rétablissement rappelé que la
convention abolisse cavasin dit saison
94 et que cette abolition en droit ne
fait que sanctionner ceux qui a été
arraché par les escarres de même dès le
mois d'août 17 ans 93 ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que les critiques
adressées à l'institution de des stars
âge adressé aux cannois ont été faites
d'une part par des conventionnels par
des révolutionnaires mais évidemment
aussi par les esclaves de même
lassé des atermoiements de la révolution
et de la convention ont arraché la
liberté l'égalité en menant un combat
difficile à saint domingue
clairement aujourd'hui qu'elles
devraient être selon vous les mots
prononcés par emmanuel macron quelle
doit être l'attitude du chef de l'état
je suis très surpris que l mâcon ne
reprennent pas à la fois l'esprit et la
lettre de la loi taubira du 10 mai et
rappelle qu effectivement l'esclavagé
son exploitation sont l'existence le
code noir ont étés consécutifs d'un
crime contre l'humanité est par ailleurs
et là aussi c'était prévu dans la loi
taubira du 10 mai cet art qu'est article
a disparu au cours de la navette
parlementaire
il était prévu à l'origine des
réparations la question jury se posent
et se couchent d'autant plus vous l'avez
signalé çà a été signalé dans le sujet
présenté aux états unis
la chose est désormais à l'agenda
politique et non pas seulement à la zone
art politique il ya une petite ville pas
très loin de chicago qui a décidé et
d'accorder pour les dix ans à venir
environ des sommes très considérable en
dollars aux descendants d'esclaves
c'est-à-dire aux infos étasunien autant
dire c'est qu'il ya encore quelques
années
et sinon qu'elle commet a été considérée
comme une revendication radical
illusoire et désormais effectivement à
l'agenda politique aux états unis et est
déjà entrée en vigueur dans certains cas
il me semble et sur ce chapitre
encore une fois la france est très en
retard puisque emmanuel macron l'anil
prononcer le mot du crime contre
l'humanité et évidemment eu moins encore
celui de réparation il faut aller donc
tu es loin que là que l'art contemporain
temps ce selon vous il faut des actes
concrets de réparation juste une
précision personne parmi eux celles et
ceux qui demandent la reconnaissance qui
est établi dans la loi du 10 mai ne
parle de repentance et il s'agit bien
plutôt d'une reconnaissance d'une
reconnaissance politique une
reconnaissance symbolique et je crois
qu'effectivement il faut aller plus loin
en termes de du côté des réparé
parce que contrairement à ce que disent
ou si un certain nombre de personnes
l'esclavagé n'est pas un passé passé ou
plus exactement ce sont les effets de l'
esclavage qui n'appartiennent pas au
passé et qui continue d'affecter les
populations afro descendantes qui vivent
principalement aux antilles et en guyane
à la réunion mais sans doute aussi en
métropole alors lors de cette journée de
mémoire de l'esclavagé
marine le pen a pris la parole elle a
dénoncé les formes d' esclavage moderne
comme le trafic d'êtres humains en
méditerranée je cite qu'encourage selon
elle son couvert d'humanisme des
voiliers des ong des dom i-gr ans quelle
est votre réaction c'est un terme
adéquat selon vous alors nous le savons
et parce que c'est d'augmenter de façon
très précise
là un certain nombre d ong ou de suaux
d'une section amitiés internationales et
de waco qu'effectivement en libye où ce
qui reste de la libye plus activement et
il est plus sain et âpre pour parler et
il y avait effectivement et c'est
maintenant très bien documenté y compris
d'ailleurs par le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés et des formes d'esclavagé de
vente d'hommes de femmes et de migrants
marine le pen ne serait bien inspirée
d'une part de condamner tous les
esclavages est également haut celui dont
la france et s'est rendu coupable de 785
aller 794 j'aimerais simplement ajouter
une chose on entend beaucoup dire que
l'esclavagé a été aboli définitivement
par la grâce du décret du 27 avril 848
ce n'est pas vrai
sous la troisième république et
notamment en afrique subsaharienne la
troisième république qui a construit et
blanc le plus grand empire colonial de
france se trouve confronté un nouvel
esclavage qui l esclavage domestique ou
de cases et cet esclavage n'a pas été
volé par les autorités coloniales comme
par les autorités métropolitaine
clairement ça veut dire aujourd'hui
qu'en 2021 il existe de nombreuses
formes d'esclavagé moderne
selon vous il existe des nombreuses
formes d'esclavagé moderne il en existe
en afrique subsaharienne il n'existe
encore dans un état en particulier l'eau
au moins elle pour serrer les skis et de
cette afrique subsaharienne la morita
ligne d'une part il le sait mieux le
mali dans les deux cas ça concerne des
centaines de milliers d'hommes de femmes
et de mineur et qui sont encore et
escales et faut-il le rappeler dans
certains cas s il arrive en france et
qu'ils arrivent à faire la démonstration
qu'ils ont été esclaves dans leur pays
d'origine ils peuvent se voir accorder
pour cette raison le statut de réfugié
par ailleurs un siècle dans d'autres
continents le en asie du sud-est et en
inde il ya encore des millions
d'esclaves pour dettes et que par
ailleurs dans un certain nombre de pays
du golfe et ailleurs il ya des
conditions de travail qui sont imposés
avec des restrictions très importantes
des droits et libertés fondamentaux
absence de véritable salaire l'ensemble
de ces éléments là étant effectivement
dans certains cas est constitutive de
l'esclavagé contemporain
merci beaucoup olivier le cour
grandmaison d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur ft france l'avenir de
l'europe vue par emmanuel macron à
strasbourg hier le chef de l'état
français a plaidé pour une europe
capable de décider plus vite et plus
fort à l'occasion du lancement de la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
je vous propose de l'écouter nous devons
là aussi retrouver de l'efficacité et de
l'ambition pouvoir face à des crises d
adversité décider plus vite et surtout
décider plus forts si nous avons résisté
ensemble à cette pandémie c'est parce
que depuis 71 ans nous avons ensemble
construit ce qui n'était absolument pas
une évidence et nous avons d'abord
résisté par notre modèle de protection
sociale par une europe de la solidarité
une unité affichée hier pour cette
journée de l'europe pourtant fragilisé
par la crise sanitaire nadège abderrazak
l'europe était déchiré avec d'autres
courageux robert schuman a rassemblé il
a uni pour que la paix sans
racine 71 ans après le chemin parcouru
est immense l'unité la solidarité sont
notre moteur il nous reste beaucoup à
faire
la renaissance européenne est devant
nous 71 ans après l'union européenne
ville l'une des plus graves crises de
son histoire après la crise financière
de 2008 la crise migratoire de 2015
voilà que la crise sanitaire liée au
kobus 19 fait voler en éclats l'unité et
la solidarité affichée par emmanuel
macron des tonnes de masques qui
disparaissent sur le tarmac des
aéroports et des aspirateurs qui
s'évapore il y a un an l'europe
s'écharpent sur le moindre équipement
médical tant les pénuries sont criantes
quelques mois plus tard bruxelles rate
le coche de la vaccination négociations
tardives trop-plein de procédures manque
de pragmatisme et les campagnes de
vaccination dans les pays de l'ue eux
patine comparée à celle menée tambour
battant au royaume uni qui venait de
quitter l'union
elles vont entraîner une pluie de
critiques sur la commission jusqu'à même
se faire remonter les bretelles par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé les
vaccins sont notre meilleure voie pour
sortir de la pandémie
non seulement ils fonctionnent mais ils
sont aussi très efficaces pour limiter
les infections
néanmoins le déploiement de ces vaccins
est d'une lenteur inacceptable
l'europe des 27 unie et solidaire montre
rapidement ses failles
la hongrie tout de suite décide de faire
cavalier seul en homologuant le vaccin
russe spoutnik vais non autorisée par
l'union européenne les pays qui ont
acheté par eux mêmes de leur propre
initiative des vaccins sans oeillères
idéologiques en se tournant notamment
vers les vaccins produits par la russie
et la chine s'en sortent mieux et les
britanniques qui ont quitté les lieux à
la fin de l'année 2020 aujourd'hui sont
à un niveau de vaccination quatre fois
supérieur à la france l'allemagne
l'italie ou l'espagne la slovaquie chez
lui emboîte le pas et l'allemagne
se dit prête elle aussi a commandé le
vaccin reçu une fois qu'il sera
autorisée par bruxelles alors que la
france elle s'entête à garder sa ligne
anti russe à la manière dont ces gérer
c'est plus un moyen de propagande et de
diplomatie agressive qui a moyen de
solidarité des sanitaires
en ce qui concerne le vaccin russe je
suis d'avis que tout vaccin autorisé par
l' agence européenne du médicament
devrait être utilisée dans l'union
européenne
je préférerais une commande de l'union
européenne mais si celle ci
n'intervenait pas alors l'allemagne
devrait agir pour elle même et c'est ce
que nous ferions don du ciel pour les un
outil de propagande pour les autres le
vaccin russe spoutnik v est loin d'être
le seul sujet de désaccord parmi les 27
le pass vaccinale est tout autant
plébiscité que critiquer certains
estiment qu'il est nécessaire pour
accélérer la réouverture des frontières
du tourisme et le retour à la vie
normale
il est urgent d'adopter en accords
comment sur la manière dont un
certificat de vaccination doit être
structuré de sorte qu'ils soient
acceptés dans tous les états membres
le certificat vert européen vise à
revenir à un début de normalité la
france l'allemagne ou les pays-bas se
sont montrés plus prudents finalement
les eurodéputés ont opté pour un
passeport sanitaires européens moins
contraignant il devrait contenir
plusieurs informations personnelles nom
prénom date de naissance numéro de
passeport le type de vaccin à réaliser
ou encore l'état du test pcr
si l'union européenne devraient survivre
à cette énième crise une chose est sûre
elle y aura laissé quelques plumes
dresser la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique
l'eau une vaccination à destination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la corrida
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les production de
vaccins
où est le mécanisme de la vaccination